so let me ask about stalling because
you've done more research is in another
amazing interview you've had the the
introduction was that you know more
about Stalin than Stalin himself you've
done incredible amount of research on
Stalin so if you could talk to him get
sort of direct research what question
did you ask of Stalin I have so many
questions I don't even know where I
would begin the thing about studying a
person like Stalin who's an immense
creature right he's exercising the power
of life and death over hundreds of
millions of people he's making decisions
about novels and films and and turbines
and submarines and and pacts with Hitler
or deals with Churchill and Roosevelt
and and occupation of Mongolia or
occupation of North Korea he's making
phenomenally consequential decisions
over all spheres of life all areas of
Endeavour and over much of the globe
much of the land mass of the earth and
so what's that like does he sometimes
reflect on the amount of power and
responsibility he has that he can
exercise does he sometimes think about
what it means that a single person has
that kind of power and does it have an
effect on his relations with others his
sense of self the kinds of things he
values in life does he sometimes think
it's a mistake that he's accumulated
this much power does he sometimes wish
he had a simpler life or is he once
again so drunk so enamored so caught up
with chemically and spiritually with
exercising this kind of power that he
couldn't live without it and then what
were you thinking I would ask him in
certain decisions that he made what were
you thinking on certain dates and
certain circumstances where you made a
decision and could have made a different
decision
can you read we call your thought
processes can you bring the decision
back was it seat-of-the-pants was it
something you'd been planning did you
just improvise or did you have a
strategy what were you guided by whose
examples did you look to when you picked
up these books that you read and you
read the books and you made pencil marks
in them is it because you absorb the
lesson there or did it really not become
a permanent lesson and was just
something that you checked and it was
like a reflex so I have many specific
questions about many specific events and
people and circumstances that I have
tried to figure out with the surviving
source materials that we have in
abundance but I would still like to
delve into his mindset and reconstruct
his mind the closer you get to Stalin in
some ways the more elusive he can become
and especially around World War two
you've already illuminated a lot of
interesting aspects about Stalin's role
in the war but it would be interesting
to ask even more questions about how
seat-of-the-pants or deliberate some of
the decisions have been
you